welcome to this video playing themselves
okay I'm playing themselves sounds like
wrong grammar okay the viral attack hmm
unfortunately i forgot the theory d5
know you play d5 only after c3 of course
here Wow is taking it that's very risky
okay let's see what happens this has
really a very deadly reputation taking
the pawn it leads to a position that is
very similar to the similar I try to
correct my pronunciation but it's stuff
similar position ok Knight f6 Sam going
towards the King side wow we Wow there
should be six what then Queen H form
maybe
yeah well Bishop g5 yeah Bishop g5 is a
move that he can play I guess I need to
I need to have an answer ready for that
we should be fine maybe I need to go
clean d 7 or something okay let's do
that so after Bishop g5 I can play a
naija form
I'm not sure if I we ever played the
correct move order
Jeff simple simple chess but not benches
what if I go green seas 6 is playing
what f3 maybe at least that is a
weakening but okay I'd like to provoke
it a weakling of the position with f3
and now probably p 8 yeah I didn't play
the the best possible way this is clear
this porn grab is completely is really
not playable it should lead to a very
very strong attack and I didn't get one
hmm yeah this feels like a bit bit of
compensation but not really decisive or
anything okay yeah probably Queen takes
to have from FC five for example yeah I
have rookie to this is why I wanted to
also provoke f3 so that the rook is
actually doing something on the second
rank
yeah very disappointing what the heck
Queen g3 H for all this yeah I what what
this better be up to six maybe wasn't
great if he gets to exchange the strong
bishop on d6 this is really a really a
problem okay I overlooked that move yeah
I really suck at the moment ah what the
heck
yeah just losing an exchange I'm blue
I'm just losing an exchange
this very little account to play to be
honest I can this rook maybe I can maybe
the queen is not so great on c5 if he
goes there and it's not doing much them
I'll look g4 yet 25 wait Biden time play
ok Knight g4 FCF 70 saying okay well
this was not so his house wasn't this
wasn't so easy mmm i have f11 very cheap
trick like Luke edge for g33 g3 takes
rook edge one made very cheap very cheap
trick but maybe if he goes to d2 or
something okay 22 great 26 hahaha what
what a move try to really yeah make fun
of me
okay it's not really threatening
anything yeah look she fought I thought
isn't as possible but is playing far
more complicated than necessary at least
if maybe it seemed wrong but it is it's
not it was necessary at all what he did
them yeah look f6 I have Quinn d3 check
ok let's see Queenie 3m at least that
rather substantial threat ok g3 I can
take with the rook h3 I can take not
easy maybe it needs to be up kings and
now and now he's on eight seconds our
MOOC g5 Butchie forever yeah actually
miscalculate wish I thought Bishop g2 I
can take here and take him check yeah
somehow I brilliant as well myself out
of this position but of course it was it
was dead lost queen g6 really wasn't
what was a bit unnecessary I mean it
it's possible it's a move but you could
just play a simple retreat or here and
it's an exchange I am I screwed up badly
in the opening
I am ia ia I am I think i think it's
it's here this is the issue i think this
is this is our guy and now i remember
now i remember i need to go here this is
this is the point exactly yeah the point
is the following here that now this is
not on because of this app ideas now
with Knight g4 this is not possible
before and rookie form the bishop is
better better here it might go here but
not in every in every case yeah now I
have this this idea for example yeah
this is much better than the game much
better I mean this is playable black is
not not hopeless but and this is really
not not cutting it I mean maybe here
Bishop g5 rupee for or something like
that yeah that's that's better even yeah
and around here it's it's it starts to
be just a pawn I have a bit of
compensation a bit but it's not enough
94 being the main problem I mean if I
need to play a little move now like
rookie seven or something then yeah just
overlook that yeah he really should
should have one probably but he played a
bit more complicated than necessary and
made made problems for himself alright
thanks for watching